James Martin,
and I'm a Jesuit priest and author of
the Jesuit Guide to almost everything
becoming a jesuit.
It's kind of a long process.
Uh,
you start a as a jesuit novice,
which is two years,
uh,
in a place called the Novitiate,
and you do a combination of prayer,
uh,
and working with the poor in the middle
of all that,
uh,
two years,
you'd do a 30 day silent retreat,
um,
based on what are known as the spiritual
exercises of sending Nicholas Loyola,
which is kind of an imaginative,
um,
placing yourself in the gospel scenes
and sort of accompanying Jesus through
the Gospel scenes imaginative.
Like,
uh,
after the Novitiate,
you take a what are called your simple
vows of poverty,
chastity and obedience.
Um,
after that you do what's called first
studies,
which is a combination of a philosophy
and theology.
Um,
and then following that you do three
years of full time work,
which is called in the Jesuits,
a regency.
Uh,
most jesuits like to,
um,
teach.
They'll teach in a high school
somewhere.
I worked a overseas at a,
in the Jesuit refugee service helping
refugees in east Africa.
Start small businesses for themselves.
So after that three years has done a,
you go to theology studies and a you
three or four years of theology studies
and if you're a priest,
um,
you get ordained at the end.
There's Jesuit brothers as well on
people who are jesuits but are not a
call to the priesthood.
Uh,
and then after ordination you work full
time for a couple of years.
I'm working in a Catholic magazine and
finally,
uh,
at the end of probably five or six years
after that,
you take what are called your final
vows.
So the whole process is pretty long.
It took me a 21 years to become a
jesuit,
which,
uh,
I think it was a little too long for my
taste.
But that's,
that's pretty average.
It takes about 20 years to,
uh,
to become a full fledged jesuit.
Uh,
I like to say it's,
um,
it's like being a made man in the mafia
or getting tenure at a university or a
becoming a partner.
You know,
you've been in for awhile,
but uh,
but you've,
you're finally finally fully accepted.
So it's a pretty long process.
Poverty is one of the three vows that we
take.
We take a vow of poverty,
chastity,
and obedience.
And,
uh,
you know,
initially stand Ignatius Loyola,
uh,
when he had his conversion experience,
he,
uh,
was injured in a battle,
and was taken home to recuperate and
started to think about doing something
else with his life.
He became very aesthetical and gave up
everything and really live like a
hermit.
Lived in a cave,
let his fingernails grow long,
his hair grow long.
And ultimately he realized that this
wasn't really doing her much good and he
needed to moderate some of this.
Um,
he ended up going back to school to
learn.
And so he thought,
well,
jesuits should be free of material
possessions,
but they don't have to live,
you know,
like they're hermits.
Like they're living in a cave and eating
twigs and things like that.
It's not a,
it's a complete poverty.
So Jesuit poverty is really about
freedom.
It's about the freedom of not owning
things.
It's about the freedom of living simply.
Um,
and it's also about the freedom to not
let anything,
any possessions come in between you and
God.
Um,
at the same time,
it's supposed to help us identify with
the poor,
uh,
where we do a lot of work with the poor.
Um,
and uh,
we're supposed to try to live as close
as possible to,
um,
what's indignation is calls a,
a family of slender means,
you know,
people who don't have a lot.
And also,
um,
it's supposed to model Christ.
Uh,
I mean,
Jesus,
when he lived on the earth was living
very simply as a very simple man.
And so those are the three things.
It frees us up for service that it makes
it makes it so we don't have a lot of
possessions to kind of like tie us down.
Uh,
it helps us identify with the poor,
uh,
and it's an imitation of Christ.
It's really trying to follow Christ in
more closely.
Yeah.
Chasse that he's the most difficult
thing to explain about religious life.
I mean,
most people think it's crazy or
unhealthy or a natural,
you don't have to.
The sex abuse crisis,
people think that a,
the sex abuse crisis came from jazz city
or from celibacy.
Um,
but it's really,
as I see it,
a different way to love a,
it's certainly not for everybody.
I mean,
clearly,
you know,
most people are called to romantic love
and married lives and having children.
Um,
but for some of us,
a,
it works and,
and really what it is,
it's a loving many people freely and
deeply.
You're not attached to just one person.
You don't have an exclusive
relationship.
So you're free to love many people,
which is not to say the people who are
married or are in a romantic
relationship,
can't love many people.
It's just to say that this is what works
best for people in religious orders.
And I find it very freeing.
Um,
I find people can be freer with me,
uh,
in a sense.
You know,
when I become close friends with
somebody,
they're not wondering,
is he becoming friends because of sex?
You know,
does he have an ulterior motive?
Something like that.
Uh,
men and women can feel comfortable with
you.
Uh,
and really a,
in a practical level,
uh,
it makes you a lot more mobile.
Uh,
you're not in a sense worried about what
your wife or husband,
um,
is going to be thinking about.
You're moving or taking a new job.
So it can be very freeing,
but it really freaks people out.
Let me chastity really,
you know,
in a culture that values sex,
and rightly,
uh,
so much.
Uh,
it really disturbs people,
but I think,
you know,
uh,
for those,
um,
people who are called to it,
it can work very well if you live at in
a healthy way,
meaning if you have friends and have
healthy work and healthy prayer life.
Um,
so I'm all for it,
but,
uh,
it's not for everybody.
I worked for GE for six years and,
um,
I had studied the Wharton School of
business beforehand,
uh,
before entering Ge.
And,
uh,
after about six years I started to
realize that this really wasn't for me.
Um,
you know,
business was a real vocation as it were
for a lot of my friends.
And,
uh,
I just got more,
more miserable,
you know,
the workload got,
um,
more difficult as anyone who works in
the corporate world knows it can be
really stressful.
And I saw some friends of mine really
enjoying the work a while.
I just seem to get bored by it.
Um,
at the same time I was getting all these
stomach problems and,
uh,
sort of stress related illnesses.
One night I came home dead tired after
this long day of work and I sort of
plopped down on our couch and turn on
the TV.
And there was this pbs documentary about
a guy named Thomas Merton who was a
trappist monk,
a cloistered monk,
and um,
I had never heard of him.
And the documentary really just
captivated me.
Um,
the look on his face,
uh,
just,
spoke this great sense of joy and peace
and calm and consolation.
And it really called out to me.
And,
uh,
that was so interesting,
that one documentary that I went out and
purchased his autobiography,
the Seventh Story Mountain,
uh,
which is pretty well known in Catholic
circles.
I'd never heard of it.
I devoured it.
I read it in a couple of nights and,
um,
I really couldn't get it out of my mind
that that's what I wanted to do.
Something like what he did.
I didn't,
I wasn't particularly religious.
Um,
I was Catholic,
but I wasn't Super Catholic.
I never thought of anything like that
before.
And I read a lot about Thomas Merton,
and one day I went up to my parish
priest and I said,
you know,
I think I'd be interested in being a
priest,
which was kind of weird because he had
never even met me before.
And he said,
well,
you know,
you should talk to the local diocese.
Um,
and you might want to talk to the
jesuits who were up the street at
Fairfield University in Connecticut.
That was the only connection I had to
the jesuits.
So I visited the jesuits at Fairfield.
They gave me some,
uh,
you know,
vocational,
uh,
literature,
kind of promotional literature about the
jesuits.
And I read it and I thought,
this is crazy.
You know,
actually ripped it up,
threw it away and thought,
this is insane.
You know,
this is not,
this is not who I am,
but,
you know,
I read some more and,
and continued to read.
Um,
around the same time I started to go to
a psychologist because of all these
stress related stomach problems as a
result of work.
And so I'm reading and thinking and
going to the psychologist at the same
time.
And finally one day he said to me,
well,
you know,
you're in this,
uh,
business world and you don't seem very
happy,
so what would you do if you could do
anything you wanted to do?
And I thought for a moment,
and I said,
oh,
I'd be a Jesuit priest.
And he said,
uh,
well,
why don't you?
And I thought,
yeah,
why don't I so,
uh,
it made sense.
And I thought,
well,
this is really something that I'm
actually interested in.
Why am I doing something that I dislike?
You know?
So I called the jesuits and,
um,
they didn't know who I was and I said,
I'm ready to enter.
And,
uh,
they were nice enough to sort of start
me on the application process,
which took a couple months,
but a couple of months later I was in,
so it was pretty rushed.
Um,
but I just say looking back on it,
it was probably,
well,
it was the best decision I've ever made.
Well,
I have to say St Ignatius Loyola,
the founder of the Jesuits who lived
from 1491 to 1556,
uh,
you know,
his spirituality,
which can be summarized as finding God
in all things,
um,
or being a contemplative in action.
The person who is,
has a sense of awareness in the midst of
a very busy world has really changed the
way I live my life.
Um,
I think,
you know,
for me,
say in Ignatius's is kind of the model
for all jesuits.
Um,
but I don't just like Jesuit saints.
I also like a saint therese of Lisieux
who was a 19th century Carmelite nun who
lived,
uh,
what she called her little way,
which was basically doing small things
with great love for God.
Um,
I love,
uh,
blessed blessing John the 23rd,
um,
who was pope from 1958 to 1963.
Uh,
cause it was so funny.
Basically,
um,
one joke from John,
the 23rd,
a journalist asked him once how many
people work in the Vatican and he said
about half of them going know.
So,
I mean,
he shows you can be someone with a sense
of humor and be a saint.
Uh,
and then finally Thomas Merton,
the a fellow whose book I read who Kinda
got him,
he started on religious life.
So those are my,
I'd say top four.
You don't need to believe in God to find
his insights useful.
Um,
it helps to understand the totality of
his message because a jesuit
spirituality without God or without
Jesus,
you know,
we'll only make partial sense.
But that being said,
um,
Saint Ignatius knew that people were on
different paths,
uh,
in their life to God and different paths
in general.
And so many of the insights are really
useful to people who are,
um,
not only devout believers,
but even doubtful seekers,
people who are agnostic or atheist
stuff.
For example,
he talks about how to make decisions,
um,
living freely,
uh,
how to be a good friend,
um,
how to work well,
uh,
how to be,
in a healthy relationship with somebody.
So there's a lot of things that you can
take from the way of sand,
ignatius,
that are applicable to anybody.
Um,
but it really to understand it in its
totality,
you have to see it as sort of a path to
God.
So I like to say that,
um,
anyone can benefit from the way of
setting niches,
but to get to the final and you really
do have to keep your eyes focused on
God.
A lot of,
uh,
ignation spirituality talks about
desire.
Um,
and that's sort of a,
a bad word and some spiritual circles
because some people equate it with just
selfish wants,
right?
Like,
I want a new car,
I want a new iphone,
I want a new pc,
something like that.
Um,
or they think of it as sexual desire,
which is,
you know,
oh my Gosh,
God forbid we should talk about sexual
desire.
I mean,
that's,
that's healthy,
right?
But desire on an even deeper level,
um,
is the desire that we have to be who we
are to be our true selves and the desire
for God.
Um,
and there's also desires that,
uh,
lead us to our vocations and what we
want to do in life.
So for example,
um,
uh,
a married couple might discover their
vocations through desire.
So the desire for sexual intimacy,
for uh,
emotional intimacy,
um,
for a,
a sort of connectedness,
I mean that brings them together.
People understand that in terms of
desire,
desire works the same way in terms of
our jobs and our vocations.
Um,
uh,
someone who was interested in a video
might be interested in it because they
feel this attraction to it.
It's really interesting.
They feel this desire for it.
Someone who's a doctor might find,
I'm talking about medicine and the body
and things like that,
just really attractive.
So,
so desires is really important thing to
pay attention to and ultimately our
desires.
Um,
I believe,
um,
our deepest desires are God's desires
for us really and,
and the deepest desires we have to be
our true self,
to really live out who we're meant to be
and what we're meant to do are the ways
that God has of drawing us to happiness
and also the ways that God has of
drawing us,
I think,
to fulfill God's desires for the world.
So,
um,
I don't think we should be too hard on
desire and the spiritual life or in any
part of life.
Yeah.
I don't think we can find true
happiness.
Uh,
you know,
this side of life.
I mean,
there's always going to be certain
suffering and struggles.
Everybody has problems in their life.
Um,
but I think,
um,
you can attain a great sense of joy and
peace if your life is centered on God.
Now that sounds really cheesy,
which does that mean?
It means,
uh,
in the ignition,
a way of looking at things,
the Jesuit way of looking at things,
a lot of freedom and detachment from
things that keep you from being
connected to God.
It means that being grateful for the
things that are blessings in your life,
uh,
it means as a contemplative in action,
being aware of all the blessings you
have in life,
but a certain amount of suffering is
inevitable in anyone's life.
I think any religion,
any really healthy religion will tell
you that.
Uh,
so,
you know,
full joy I think is only achieved with
God.
Uh,
you know,
in the afterlife,
uh,
God willing.
But I think you can experience a lot of
joy in your life today on earth.
Thank God.
Sometimes your own shows where people
are aggressive or confrontational.
And it's a important to remember always
to be charitable because,
you know,
when I'm talking,
it's not just representing me or talking
about my book.
I'm also for better or worse
representing the church.
And so if I come off as being
argumentative or mean or snappish or
whatever,
then people will say,
well,
look,
the Catholic church,
you know,
once again,
they're being,
uh,
whatever.
So charities,
the first thing,
um,
and uh,
you know,
I sometimes get nervous about the,
um,
the topics that people choose to bring
up.
You never know what they're going to
bring up.
Uh,
but on Kobe or it's a lot of fun.
I mean,
he,
he himself as a Catholic,
so I know that he understands what I'm
talking about.
Uh,
he's funny.
Um,
one of the great challenges of being
that chose just not laughing.
I mean,
he's so outrageous sometimes and so
unpredictable that the things he says
just make me laugh.
One time I was on and,
um,
we were talking about the recession and,
uh,
how people find God in the midst of
difficult times.
And I said that,
uh,
were sometimes more open to God's,
activity in our lives when we're more
vulnerable,
which is true because,
you know,
when our defenses are down,
we can let God and more easily,
which is,
which happens when people are sick or
when they're going through difficult
times.
Uh,
and he said,
you make God sound like an opportunistic
disease.
And I thought,
I guess I do,
but it was hard not to laugh because it
was so silly.
Um,
but yeah,
I really enjoy being on the show.
You know,
on the one hand are people who say that
Anti Catholicism is just as bad as
antisemitism or homophobia or racism.
It's not clearly,
it's not as virulent and not as
prevalent on the other end are people
that say it doesn't exist at all.
You know,
but,
but it does basically.
Um,
I think a lot of portrayals of nuns and
priests,
uh,
on TV and in the movies or
stereotypical,
um,
you know,
post sex abuse crisis frequently when
you see a pre show up on a TV cop show,
you know,
he's usually a pedophile.
A nuns are usually portrayed as like
ninnies basically are stupid.
I mean,
I always say,
here are women who kind of built the
Catholic healthcare system in the United
States and ran universities and,
but when they come on TV,
they're,
they're portrayed as being idiots
basically.
So there some subtle Antica phalluses
when that,
um,
I think,
uh,
you know,
you hear people taking pot shots at a
priest for being celibate or being
pedophiles are being insane or whatever.
So I think there's a lot of stuff that
slides by,
uh,
you know,
on TV and in the movies that would never
be allowed to happen with other groups.
You know,
I mean if you portrayed it rabbi or an
email like that,
people would rightfully complained.
But in a way,
I think because we live in a largely
Protestant culture,
um,
I think because of the sex abuse crisis,
and I think because of,
uh,
you know,
some suspicion about the Vatican and
Catholic theology in a sense anti
Catholicism is more acceptable.
In fact,
one person once called it the last
acceptable prejudice.
So it's there.
Um,
but I think we need to keep in sort of a
context exactly what that means.
It's not,
it's not as virulent as it as some other
stereotypes are,
but it is present.
I think it's gotten worse because of the
sex abuse crisis.
Uh,
I mean,
I think things are said about priests
and Celibacy,
uh,
which are,
you know,
stereotypes basically.
So you take a very small population of
priests who have committed these crimes,
then you magnify it and you say,
well,
that applies to all.
Praise then and,
uh,
you know,
I reached out in,
in,
uh,
mainstream newspapers and on tv and you
hear jokes and things like that.
And you know,
as a priest myself,
you know,
who keeps his valves,
uh,
it's offensive basically.
And I often say to people,
you know,
would you say this about rabbis?
You know,
would you say this about the moms?
And the answer is no.
But somehow people think,
um,
because of the sex abuse crisis,
it's okay to stereotype all Catholics.
You know,
all Catholics are like this.
All bishops are like this,
all priests are like this and which
would never fly for any other religious
groups.
So I just think it's a basically unfair,
I think he's really started to do some
really important things.
I think is meeting with the victims,
uh,
during his visit to Deanna to the United
States was a historic and really
unprecedented.
Uh,
I think though that there's always more
that can be done for the sex abuse
crisis in 2002,
the US bishops met in Dallas,
uh,
to formulate their a zero tolerance
policy,
which I think was necessary.
Um,
but I think that,
you know,
the clerical culture that gave rise to
that a sex abuse crisis,
which is essentially,
you know,
a few very sick men,
uh,
who were moved around from parish to
parish,
uh,
you know,
by some bishops,
um,
you know,
for fear of quote unquote causing
scandal that that's more of a cultural
type thing.
I think that needs to be addressed.
So I think what the church needs to do
is to have a culture of much more
transparency.
Uh,
and frankly,
you know,
when these guys do these things,
they need to be kicked out.
And then in the United States,
that's already happened.
Um,
so I don't think you'll see it in the
United States.
You might hear reports of ones that
happened,
you know,
maybe in the sixties and seventies.
But,
you know,
going ahead,
there is the zero tolerance policy.
Um,
I think other countries are starting to
realize that now,
um,
what needs to be done,
it really needs to be just sort of taken
out root and branch and blamed on the
right sources.
It has nothing to do with celibacy,
has nothing to do with,
uh,
you know,
gay clergy,
anything like that.
Neither of those two things lead to
pedophilia.
It has to do,
I think with this culture of secrecy and
the wrong headed notion that we
shouldn't quote unquote cause scandal by
revealing some of these things.
So,
so I hope the Catholic Church really
takes the lead,
um,
in showing other organizations about
this because,
you know,
I mean most sex abuse takes place in
families,
you know,
their sex abuse in schools or sex abuse
in children's organizations like the boy
scouts and the girl scouts.
So I think that the Catholic Church has
an opportunity here to really take the
lead and be in the vanguard of
preventing children from being abused.
Glenn Beck's comment really betrayed,
I think a fundamental misunderstanding
of the Gospel.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
Jesus in the 25th Chapter of the Gospel
of Matthew basically says that the
litmus test for how we're going to be
judged at the end of our lives is not
what church we pray in,
how we pray,
even how often we'd go to church.
It's how we treat the poor.
I mean,
it's pretty cut and dried.
You know,
if you want to enter into heaven,
treat the poor.
Well,
um,
now,
uh,
social justice is a way of looking at
what keeps people poor.
Uh,
and as the church and its 2000 year
history has reflected on Jesus's
commandment to serve the poor and love
the poor,
it's realized that we need to look at
what keeps them poor.
Uh,
it's not enough to just give someone a
handout.
As important as that is,
it's important to,
to look at what keeps the people poor.
So someone told me the other day the
Gospel story of the,
um,
uh,
the Good Samaritan where the guy sees
someone by the side of the road who has
been beaten and he takes care of him.
He brings it back to an end.
He dresses his wounds.
He gives him money for the,
uh,
for staying overnight.
In the end.
Uh,
someone said to me today,
we'd also be looking at why that road is
dangerous.
You know,
what is it that makes that road
dangerous?
Um,
how can we fix the situations that lead
for crime and things like that?
So,
so that's what social justices,
it's basically working for justice
society.
Now,
how anybody can be against that is
beyond me,
frankly.
He compared to people who support social
justice to Stalin and Hitler.
And,
uh,
I just found that,
frankly outrageous,
there've been people other than me that
have,
uh,
talked about this and he's responded by
saying,
well,
I didn't mean this.
I what I meant was this.
I meant that charities,
okay,
as long as it's not,
uh,
you know,
a sponsored by the government.
But,
you know,
once again,
how else does the community respond?
Uh,
socially,
other than through governmental
policies?
I mean,
you can do things individually,
you can do things in church,
but I mean,
we have,
we have all sorts of public works,
you know,
in terms of social security and Medicare
and Medicaid and,
you know,
even like public transportation.
I mean,
that in a sense is providing for the
common good.
Um,
so I still think he basically,
um,
just doesn't like the idea of helping
the poor.
And,
uh,
I think oftentimes this critique of
social justice is really just a thinly
veiled excuse for not wanting to deal
with the poor.
And a lot of people find the poor,
uh,
as Pope John Paul said,
irksome intruders,
you know,
into our comfortable life.
But you know,
what good is the gospel if it doesn't
disturb you as supposed to disturb you?
Yeah,
it's very hip to be spiritual but not
religious.
Um,
almost everybody I know says their
spiritual now.
That's good.
I mean,
spiritual is good.
Spiritual means the,
you have a relationship with God.
Spiritual means that you,
you connect with God.
That a spirituality is an important part
of your life.
That you try to lead a good life.
He try to be in concert with a what your
relationship with God tells you,
which is terrific.
I mean you,
you have to have that,
um,
religious on the other hand,
uh,
in current parlance is bad because that
seems to say that,
oh,
I believe in this,
uh,
organization that has all these
hidebound dogmas and beliefs and I would
never be able to,
um,
belong to an organization that tells me
what to think.
Things like that.
Um,
the problem with being spiritual but not
religious is that you're not part of a
community in a sense.
Um,
and so there's no one to sort of bump up
against to tell you when you might be a
little off track,
um,
as well.
Um,
you're not really able to connect,
uh,
in your spiritual life with other
people.
There was a great saying from Isaac
Hecker,
who was the 19th century,
uh,
American priest and he said,
religion enables us to,
um,
connect and correct.
So we connect with other people were
naturally social animals.
Right?
And we like to worship in common.
That makes sense.
We connect with one another,
uh,
and were corrected.
Uh,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
if I have a direct line to God,
right?
That means that by definition,
anything I think or say is from God.
Right?
And that's as we know a problem.
So being spiritual without being
religious means that you're lacking kind
of the wisdom of the community,
you know,
as well as the support of the community.
You know,
when you're,
when you're sort of struggling,
um,
being religious without being spiritual
is just as bad.
Being religious without being spiritual
just means all you're doing is following
the rules.
You're just following the rules.
You're just listening to the community
and yet you're not reflecting on things,
uh,
yourself.
So the one thing is what Jesus was
warning against being religious without
being spiritual.
You know,
does some of the religious authorities
of his day when I'm warning against,
is being spiritual without being
religious,
which is much more common today.
So I think it's not an either or.
I think it's a both end.
The worst career advice I've ever had
was when I was at the Wharton School,
uh,
studying business.
And,
um,
I went to my faculty advisor and,
uh,
you know,
a wharton students are supposed to be
focused really on the business.
And I said that I would be interested in
taking an American poetry class.
And he said that the stupidest thing
I've ever heard,
he said,
don't take an American poetry class.
It's a waste of time.
No one will care if you ever studied
American poetry when you want to get a
job at ge.
So I would strongly advise you not to do
that unless you want to be thought,
uh,
you know,
not serious about your job.
So fortunately I didn't take his advice
and it's one of the few courses I
remember very well from school.
Um,
the best career advice I've ever gotten
was from that psychologist who said,
uh,
what would you do if you could do
anything you wanted to do?
I think that's a question I ask a lot of
people and it's very clarifying for
people because frequently have these
expectations put on us by family,
by friends.
You know what you should do.
A friend of mine called that a shooting
all over yourself.
S h o u.
rather than saying,
you know,
what are my desires?
What do I like?
What gets me excited?
Um,
and I tend to think that,
um,
you will do better at things that you're
really interested in because you're
going to spend more time with that.
You're going to read about it outside of
work and you'll be enthusiastic about
it.
So when I was at,
uh,
at Ge,
working in business,
I realized that the people who were
going to do well,
where the people who loved it,
you know,
my friends would read the Wall Street
Journal and say,
Oh,
this is fascinating.
And I would say,
how can you read that stuff?
You can say it like,
oh,
this is fantastic.
How can you not read it?
And so this notion of,
you know,
following your desires,
I think is really important.
And,
you know,
what would you do if you could do
anything you wanted to do is probably
the best career advice or the best
question I've ever been asked about my
career.